hey youtubers is Charlie since the
terminus people on Walking Dead have
kind of been added as cannibals I wanted
to do a bonus video explaining who the
hunters are in the comics since they
share a lot of similarities
it's also possible we could see some
comic book moments from the fear of the
hunters storyline in the comics so I'll
try to explain what those are whenever I
post my review tonight there is also a
new round of the giveaway is starting
tonight so all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment while I was making this they
also announced two new characters so
I'll explain who they are at the end of
the video so just a general spoiler
warning for everything through the
season five premiere but as mentioned
the hunters are a group of cannibals in
the comics they're not exactly like the
termites but they appear in issues 61
through 66 so if you do want to read
along in the comics you should check out
vol 11 fear of the hunters it just
combines all those the origins of the
termites and the origins of the hunters
in the comics are just a little bit
different but the leader of the hunters
is named Chris and he does look a little
bit like Gareth so just a couple
differences between the termites and the
hunters the termites came from terminus
like a very large place the hunters were
localized to a very small area and even
though terminus just exploded and
there's probably only a few of them left
the hunters were always a small group
the other big difference is the reason
they became cannibals on the show the
termites only became cannibals after the
crazy people took over terminus and then
they took it back
the hunters became cannibals just
because they ran out of food and they
decided that hunting people was easier
than hunting animals Scott Gimple
compared terminus to a really sinister
episode of the office like the office
with cannibals the hunters were never
really like that I mean they were always
just a little bit more evil they did
treat what they were doing in a mundane
way but I never thought of the hunters
in the comics as being like an episode
of The Office one of the things that
makes the comic book characters just way
crazier is that they ate their children
and at terminus they did eat each other
but I don't think that they went that
far we actually never saw any children
at terminus they probably just avoided
that on the show all together just
dealing with that all together or AMC
told them no you can't eat children if
you remember when they were on the kill
floor that body right there was actually
confirmed to be Garrett's brother so
they definitely did eat each other like
no one was say
the terminus I mean you became food if
you died at least they didn't kill
children
maybe that's actually why they decided
to kill Lizzie and mica before everyone
got to terminus the way the survivors
meet up with the hunters in the comics
is a little bit different - they're
essentially already on the road to
Washington DC and in episode 1
Abraham was just kind of teasing telling
everyone about that I do think they'll
head there eventually in the show but in
the comics they essentially run into a
father Gabriel and the hunters on route
they don't get super specific about
where they are on the map but it's
somewhere between Atlanta and Washington
DC Scott Gimple did tease on the show
this year that we would see some
familiar big places that had changed so
I think they will go to Atlanta at some
point it's just that a few that comic
book locations are very specific to some
places that we've seen in the trailers
like most notably father Gabriel's
Church which becomes part of a big
hunter storyline it's all just more
evidence that they're gonna be doing
some hunter specific moments during
tonight's episode as a group though the
hunters are just like a crucible for
Rick and the survivors to emerge from
being that much stronger and as we saw
at last season Rick of all from farmer
Rick to crazy Rick or went back to being
crazy Rick depending on how you look at
it even if they do comic book moments
tonight I think that the hunter
storyline will diverge on the show I
think there'll be some big differences
for instance even though Garrett's
jacket looks just like Chris's then
obviously he's an amalgam of Chris in
the comic books his storyline in the
comics is relatively self-contained
gareth last season after the finale was
up to cast regular they only do things
like that when they're intending on
using actors in most of the episodes so
I think that Garrett will just have a
few crisp moments I think it's
interesting that they've been using the
hunt or be hunted language and a lot of
the promos it just implies that Rick and
the survivors are just gonna be total
badasses or they're not gonna be as easy
prey anymore we didn't see Gareth die
last week I do think he survived and
obviously he's a cast regular so they're
not gonna kill him in the first episode
it's possible that the survivors could
capture him or some of the termites Rick
really wants to kill everyone so I don't
think that they're gonna let a bunch of
people live somebody ask Scott Gimple
about the big villain this season like
if we were gonna see a big governor type
villain he did say there would be
someone as evil as the governor they're
not going to do another governor
I mean it'll just be someone that's
really really bad I don't know that
that's gonna be Gareth he's like a
cannibal hipster and hipsters are mostly
harmless I mean they're mostly annoying
feel free to make any evil hipster jokes
you want though I just think that Gareth
is going to be a much bigger character
than Chris was in the comics I'm trying
to purposefully avoid you know how the
hunters storyline goes down so if you
have read the comics just please use
spoiler tags if you want to talk about
it in the comments I would like to see
the survivors captured Gareth I mean
it'd be interesting to see Rick go super
dark and just start killing everyone I
don't necessarily think that's gonna
happen though even though they implied
that that's what he wants to do just
look forward to the survivors hunting
the termites
you know hunt the hunters it's really
interesting to think about how far Rick
is gonna go this season he is the center
of the group even though it can be
relatively balanced I mean Carol's the
big force and Daryl obviously has a lot
of influence but I do see a lot of
Rick's craziness kind of bleeding out
into the other characters like Sasha for
instance kind of looks like she's
turning into Andrea from the comics I'm
actually really looking forward to that
because Andrea in the comics was a big
badass just in general I feel like this
season's gonna be really big for Andrew
Lincoln I'm really excited to see him
just beat absolutely nuts I know a lot
of people are wondering how long he's
gonna stay with the show it's possible
he could just write it right into the
ground he doesn't get paid as much as
say like Big Bang Theory actors get paid
but it is a pretty sweet deal I mean the
fandom is so huge that it could sustain
the show indefinitely there's that crazy
talk about AMC wanting to go through
season 12 I don't necessarily think
that's gonna happen I think a lot of
it's gonna have to do with how well the
companion show does that's just what
they're calling the spin-off show that's
gonna start next year
that actually reminds me so they're
casting two new characters they've
already picked one of them they're still
looking for the other one the first one
is Andrea Breckenridge from American
Horror Story she's gonna play someone
named Samantha it's not someone from the
comics but it's possible they're making
her somewhere from the comics and just
giving her a different name just like
they did with Gareth her character
description reads attractive strong
smart charming and articulate woman with
a vulnerable side she's a mother with a
bohemian spirit and a talented artist
we're not going to see her for a while
they just announced her casting last
week and they've already shot about half
the season so we definitely won't see
her till next year it's possible if the
group makes it to Washington
DC by next year that's where we'll see
her she'll be one of the Alexandria safe
zone characters if you never saw her on
American Horror Story she usually played
some sort of temptress with really
gruesome consequences like if you had
sex with her you were probably gonna die
it doesn't necessarily mean that she's
gonna be having sex with Rick or
anything like that it just sounds like
they're casting her to be an attractive
person the other new character is named
Donna which is kind of funny because
that's Billie and Ben's mom's name from
the comics if you remember they gave
that storyline to Lizzie and mica they
haven't announced any actors for the
role yet they're still casting women
it's rumored that Kate Burton from
scandals their top pick but again that
would be another character to show up in
the second half of the season there's
also the new character named Noah who we
haven't seen yet he was cast a long time
ago so presumably we're gonna see him
sometime in the first half of this
season he's being played by Tyler James
Williams from Everybody Hates Chris he's
not specifically someone from the comics
but it sounds like he's gonna be in at
least a few episodes so I don't think
we'll meet him till after the survivors
leave father Gabriel's Church which I do
think we're gonna see tonight I will be
posting my episode 2 review after the
episode airs tonight so be sure to
subscribe to get that if you have any
special requests for bonus videos like
comic stuff or TV show stuff I'm totally
happy to do both I'm also probably gonna
stream some of the telltale Game on my
video game channel there's a link for
that in the description so everyone get
pumped the survivors are gonna kick some
serious ass tonight you can click here
for my episode 2 video add the
annotation as soon as I post it and
click here for this week's Q&A thank you
so much for watching so let's all
high-five I'll see you guys in a little
bit